[Musique]
bozo a27 udon said no very mission in
Hong Kong a party plan Lucia module vo
festival Internacional de fin de
Marrakech au niveau de met pacifist
gusta in Osaka nice back you know
Jamaica via awesome for us gusto know
deja shows acedia al actor Australian
Simon Baker
Eliquis oignon Priyanka Chopra d'accord pourquoi
je ne savais pas de quoi nous
parlons mais c'est ce que désolé nous
parlons d'arts et de cinéma et de toutes
ces bonnes choses d'accord
c'est votre première fois au Festival
international du film de Marrakech non  ce n'est pas que
j'étais ici mais il y a quatre ou cinq ans,
ils montraient quelques-uns de mes
films cette année-là et j'étais venu y
assister c'était une grande année pour le cinéma indien
c'était 100 ans de cinéma indien cette année-là
je me souviens
et Marrakech était  rendre un grand hommage aux
acteurs, aux talents et aux réalisateurs
issus du cinéma indien et cette
expérience pour vous venant représenter
le cinéma indien avec beaucoup de vos pairs
, j'imagine que c'est cela qui a créé un
gr  manger le sens de la communauté et venir si
malheureux que j'étais le seul à venir
ici seul parce que le jour où mes pairs sont
sortis de mon emploi du temps alors j'avais j'étais le
seul que tu étais parti arrivé ils oh
non ils ont ouvert la chose et ils ont ouvert
le festival  et je suis entré comme le dernier
jour ou quelque chose comme ça et j'étais vraiment
dégoûté mais je n'ai rencontré personne
mais c'était bien mais le cinéma indien ouais
c'est énorme qu'est-ce
que tu prends ça au sérieux j'adore ça as-tu fait ça en
jouant indien  le cinéma est, vous savez
parce que cette année était célébrée, vous
savez, il y a un projecteur sur le
cinéma australien qui, si pour moi, vous savez que je suis un
acteur australien et je suis maintenant
devenu cinéaste et réalisateur et pour que mon
film soit inclus dans  tant de films
que j'ai grandi dans des films qui ont aidé à former
qui j'étais en tant qu'artiste et en tant que
conteur en tant qu'acteur, je pense que je
me souviens avoir regardé Picnic at Hanging
Rock quand j'avais 16 ans à l'école, nous l'avons
étudié et j'ai regardé ce film donc  ces
films une grande partie de  moi et je sais en tant
qu'artiste aujourd'hui qui je suis en tant qu'artiste, donc nous
avons une très petite industrie en Australie
et maintenant indicee Industries est vraiment nous
avons le soutien du gouvernement mais cela
soutient la culture de l'industrie
et parce que nous n'avons pas le public
que vous auriez en Inde, donc
c'est vraiment important, c'est un grand honneur,
mais c'est aussi très important pour notre
industrie australienne de se rassembler et
de pouvoir se
soutenir et s'encourager en
tant que cinéastes, ce serait un si
bon exemple parce que  il y a tellement de
talents australiens incroyables et pas seulement
en termes d'acteurs ou d'artistes à
Hollywood aussi, je veux dire que vous voyez
tellement de talents venir de là-bas que
c'est un témoignage du fait que vous
avez probablement une industrie incroyable,
ça n'a tout simplement pas été  bien exposés au monde,
nous n'avons pas de
public pour regarder des films, les gens
doivent aller voir des films australiens que j'ai
regardés et une émission de téléréalité apaisante et
c'est tellement  drôle et c'est des
couples australiens diva Brides vous ce que vous regardez
en Australie oui je viens de le découvrir
cette semaine en fait c'est tellement absurde
complètement à l'opposé de ce que vous
essayez de faire et de parler de
cinéma australien incroyable désolé je fais
c'est bien c'était comme bien je  sais
que quand tu es venu c'était il y a quatre
ans oui la première fois c'était que la première
fois qu'il était allé à Marrakech oui c'était
ouais c'était la première fois que j'allais à l'
homme j'étais tes expériences j'étais très
excité d'atterrir  à Casablanca
d'abord à cause des droits du film oh mon
Dieu, je vais y entrer ouais et je
ne l'ai pas fait mais dès que je suis arrivé à
Marrakech et je me souviens que j'étais ici
pendant très peu de temps c'était juste un  un jour ou
deux mais être dans les hôtels à regarder l'
architecture les gens l'excitation
de la nourriture oh mon dieu leur nourriture juste tout
ça je pense qu'en tant que culture c'est si
beau comme quelqu'un qui aime les vêtements
j'aime j'aime regarder le genre de
tissus  les gens portent ici je  c'est juste
magique j'ai l'impression que chaque kilomètre et vous
savez que c'est juste qu'il y a une magie
là-dedans il y a une aura et une attente d'une
aura que c'est la première fois que je vais à
Marrakech mais tout ce que j'avais était les
références visuelles où j'avais vu le Maroc spécifiquement
Marrakech dans les films à droite et ensuite être
ici et faire l'expérience des odeurs et de
l'inclusivité des gens, le mur
est tellement incroyable qu'il est beau pour tout le monde
et si gentil aussi aussi le festival
d'ailleurs je le trouve si inclusif de
toutes sortes de cinéma et  présenter et
vous faire connaître des gens de partout
et différents comme l'Américain indien australien,
vous la Grande-Bretagne française, comme toutes
sortes de cinéastes et de
créateurs de goût du cinéma se réunissant
sous un même toit et pouvant simplement faire
ça ouais et comme juste avoir une
conversation et  avoir une perspective
et c'est tellement cool quand je suis venu ici la dernière
fois que j'étais ici pendant deux nuits et j'ai
fini par me faire tellement d'amis avec qui je suis
toujours ami maintenant qui sont tous  dans
le monde entier mais juste d'une nuit une
conversation un verre de vin grand
cinéma indien et Bollywood je ne suis pas je
ne pense pas que le Bollywood pense le
chant et la danse je ne suis pas vraiment
bon je ne suis pas trop mauvais
danser  en fait, vous savez voir la chose à
propos de comme je veux je veux en fait vous
expliquer cette chose les gars d'accord
beaucoup de gens pensent que Bollywood vous
savez et quand c'est ma bête noire
quand je regarde comme si vous connaissiez n'importe quel
service de streaming ils  ont des genres corrects
donc ils sont comme la comédie drame d'action
Bollywood ouais je sais mais ça a été des
sortes de comédies d'horreur d'action peu
importe pour que nous puissions vous trouver un film
où vous n'avez pas de père ouais je ne
veux pas absolument je peux vous trouver un film nous
je n'ai pas de dicton que quelqu'un d'autre le fasse
pour vous je serai damné Ola toute notre musique
est en fait par des musiciens incroyables et
nous appellerons des chanteurs de lecture et ils
chantent pour nous donc en gros je veux dire nous en tant
qu'acteurs nous apprenons à danser  vraiment bien
et peut-être que vous connaissez le jeu  un peu
donc le bollywood bollywood lui-même est
séparé du bengali oui
Bollywood est un hindi
indistinct Je vais filmer apporte un privilège
Godley de je veux dire en fait Bollywood est
un terme qui a été inventé il y a quelques années
pour un type spécifique de dans les années 70  il y
avait un type spécifique de film masala qui
était autrefois fait du cinéma d'évasion si vous pouviez s'il vous
plaît ouais masala comme un mélange de
tout ce que vous savez que vous avez comme le
suspense dramatique de la comédie d'action et vous savez que
tout se réunit donc depuis lors à
cause de Bombay étant avec un être  Je
pense que nous avons compris que le terme allait à
Bollywood, mais cela ressemble en fait
à Hollywood, ce qui n'est pas amusant,
mais vous savez, j'ai maintenant travaillé dans les
deux carrières parce que j'ai également travaillé
aux États-Unis, je pense que je peux voir le
la perspective de la raison pour laquelle c'est bloqué, je suppose
parce que cela aide les gens à comprendre
quelque chose de complètement différent
et je pense que même avec le cinéma australien,
ce sera quelque chose que vous
connaissez dans toutes les industries quand je  t doit
je pense aller culturellement plus grand alors il
doit avoir son unicité mhm et j'ai l'impression
que maintenant les gens commencent à
comprendre qu'à propos de Bollywood que vous
savez ce que c'est vraiment et peut-être que c'est
la chose à voir avec le cinéma australien
qu'est-ce que c'est vraiment
eh bien c'est beaucoup de choses parce que
nous avons une société vraiment multiculturelle
et puis nous avons
des Australiens autochtones les premiers
Australiens, ils sont la plus ancienne
culture existante au monde, c'est soixante mille
ans, c'est incorrect
et toute une histoire orale et ainsi de suite  rien
n'est écrit donc des histoires donc la
narration vient littéralement c'est c'est
dans le sol Wow c'est dans les étoiles c'est
dans la trace tu sais je suis désolé j'ai la
chair de poule
non je c'est là où c'est
chaque  fois que je suis allé à Melbourne,
Melbourne ou Sydney et j'ai été plusieurs
fois à Adélaïde, la seule chose que vous
voyez certainement à propos de l'Australie est la
diversité et le nombre de types
de personnes différentes  genres de pensées
et le genre d'histoires que vous racontez
la culture
à Melbourne en particulier j'ai adoré c'était
incroyable alors j'entends que la narration
doit être fascinante là-bas ouais je suis vous
savez et je pense que nous avons vraiment seulement
atteint le bout  je voyais juste la
pointe de l'iceberg
potentiellement de l'évolution de la
profondeur des histoires que nous pouvons raconter
parce que vous savez que nous étions un
pays colonisé et que les
colonisateurs pouvaient avoir les voix les plus fortes alors
maintenant nous sommes triés  d'arriver, espérons-le,
au point où les colonisateurs permettent à
plus de voix et à des voix plus diverses de
passer et je pense que c'est l'avenir de
la culture de notre cinéma et c'est
excitant c'est cool c'est une grande
évolution si nous pouvons simplement garder la planète sur laquelle
il vivra  vous savez que nous pouvons tous
profiter de beaucoup plus d'histoires et les partager
et c'est pour moi de venir à un
festival comme celui-ci, c'est là que nous pouvons
partager cette fenêtre sur les
mondes les uns des autres absolument et et plus  t les
films ont des thèmes très universels qui
sont très liés, vous ne comprenez peut-être pas
oui, vous comprenez peut-être
comment cette personne vit, nous
comprenons le dilemme avec lequel cette personne
vit et vous savez que vous luttez avec
son identité car c'est en quelque sorte ainsi que nous
comprenons qui nous  sont comme des humains à travers
ce prisme et pour moi c'est puissant c'est
vraiment je veux dire finalement quelques
fois j'y pense vraiment
comment les gens qui sans sous-titres
parfois ou comme quand vous
regardez différents films le cinéma voyage
et transcende les frontières il transcende
la langue transcende les ethnies c'est en
quelque sorte cette chose magique qui
nous transporte vers autre chose
et c'est parce que finalement chaque
être humain ressent juste que beaucoup de choses
il y a de la colère il y a de la tristesse il y a de l'
émotion il y a de la cupidité
dans un mixeur et il en
ressort une histoire incroyablement différente,
c'est pourquoi nous avons été  capable d'évoluer tellement
et de raconter tellement d'
histoires différentes du monde entier, mais
en même temps, vous
avez des êtres humains de différentes parties
du monde qui sont simplement attirés par cela en
tant qu'industrie, j'ai l'impression que le cinéma est
devenu ce qu'il  c'est parce qu'il offre
ce genre de fenêtre c'est la grande
forme d'art empathique absolument clairement nous
aimons notre travail j'adore discuter avec vous
c'était vraiment agréable de discuter avec vous
sérieux à propos de fait maintenant vraiment et Simon
merci beaucoup
merci
[Musique]
vous